all right so this is mystery dungeon
this was hilarious
like it's it's not an episode that's
like oh wow where the story went and
everything I mean it's brilliant but
just the the slapstick in it and and
these characters surprisingly working
pretty well off each other honestly it's
um it's Ice King
shelby's and yeah tree trunks Lemongrab
I always forgive noter neptr yeah in
this room I thought was gonna be sort of
like a five strangers looking for an
exit and searching attics it was a yeah
I was gonna be like the Twilight Zone
episode especially because you see in
the opening the the hand with the little
moon but uh but it's not it's them going
through this weird dungeon trying to get
through and all these fairies kooky
things that they come across and finally
at the end you figure out that the Ice
King actually kidnapped them all and act
them out and he needed them to get
through this dungeon because it was this
metal is a Magi Magi who anything
anything you throw there will come to
life and he brings his Fionna and cake
fan fiction hoping the characters that
come to life he throws the book in and
just the book comes to life with arms
and hands even a little cards on they
find an exit Finn and Jake are in it for
like a moment they just see them escape
and then the ice cream closes his eyes
and he says oh you can exist in the
world of imagination Fionna and cake and
you just see them watching him and it's
any one more it's any one more sad than
the guys King right now watching this
right now yeah brilliant last line so I
think it's like it's the setups like
kind of flying it's like okay whatever
just serve let's see what happens we
throw his characters together but it it
is pretty funny and the characters are
good but it's it's the slapstick the
slapstick in this one is so good the rat
coming out
lemongrab yelling punching it of
anything well pilots inside the using
tree Jones as the bait and just the way
the thing comes up and eats her than her
cutting her way out
well actually what I love about that
part is of course it's supposed to be
Shelby yes and he's like I know what we
can do
well then it's tree trunks and it's like
wait a minute
when he came up with it still oh yeah
Shelby's like you know what yeah I know
exactly what to do and yeah just the the
timing of the violence on this wife just
thought was so funny and I think having
these all these characters that in their
own way with the exception maybe she'll
be uh in their own way they're all kind
of annoying yeah but they're
entertainingly annoying I know you don't
like tree trunks yeah and actually it's
one of my favorite damn things in this
episode it stops paying attention to her
notice and everyone's just kind of like
whatever and ice Kings right he's like
oh wait what's he saying no it's okay
you know it is when when I was growing
up I used to hate grandpa's Simpson
sense and now he's one of my favorite
characters because I love hearing the
rambling so I'm always wondering if I
saw this as a kid what I hate tree
trunks
you know cuz I might be uh she's slowing
down the action and everything's coming
to a halt for her and but yeah now it's
just she's so bizarre in her own little
world she just cracked me up and I love
how everything does just never seems to
end just we think it and it keeps coming
yet it just it cracks me up so I can
easily see how it kills me so ya know I
thought it was funny oh my god the lemon
grill Lemongrab Lemongrab Lemongrab
first of all again I know he keeps
saying it all the time he should be
annoying but he's not there's just some
than about Lemongrab that voice it the
most annoying voice but the funniest
voice but I have to say the rat scene is
probably my most favorite scene ever
I won't ever in the history of ever
it was funny enough when he just did the
play I didn't expect him to just like
whack this rabbit like boom the rats
dead that was funny enough he just like
I can't he just grabbed it alright he
sticks his face on he's eating it and
it's just ridiculous and gross and
horrible and so good and I don't know
about the rest of the world but I know
there are times where I get so hungry
that's why you should always feed me
always of course you won't punch you and
get whatever's in your body I just I
can't get over that see that's I I don't
know why is that just I think if you
explain it like you know it's kind of
funny but seeing it with these
characters and with them constantly
screaming and thinks just coming out and
none of them are ever quiet about
anything they're just always free minn
their scream in their own way or they're
overreacting their own way to just when
they rat comes up for and the screen
just punch it while he's still screaming
even though we're at the mouth I mean
you still see I think he's still
screaming and I always think to myself
okay this is gonna be the episode where
I'm finally gonna find him and I'm gonna
be like okay lemongrab has finally worn
out as welcome but it's like damn so
funny there's a part of me that
legitimately wants to hate him because
something just seems off balance about
the universe that I find this guy's so
funny but he really is just so it's just
something delivery that maybe there's an
episode where he's just the overstays
but not yet I haven't seen it yet he
still cracks me up oh I love in the
beginning when he first wakes up he
starts saying what's on the wall he's
just like twisting his head around
you say words on the wall they're all
words look at every wall words yeah look
every has his own dialogue law or not
dialogue his own uh yeah everything he
has his own dialect I guess you could
say like everybody has his own wall
words you know just words there are wall
words I mean and he's so convicted it
has to sound epic waste there's a wall
of words yeah um I loved with nectar
when they're like crawling and he's like
sitting there trying to explain to Ice
King that no you're my papi and all that
oh she could make pies I could make pies
too
don't you remember Paw Paw look over
there
I mean poor little neptr doesn't you
know know what's going on yes Ken yep
there's the only one that I there's
nothing wrong with him but there is
always something like yeah I always sort
of seemed like no okay yeah maybe maybe
that is yeah like the idea is like Jesse
is kind of forgettable somebody pops up
I'm like oh you know what does anything
bad or Robbie's nothing really wrong
with them there's just I know it's like
the other characters oh yeah I loved
when they're running they comes that
part where at least like a spiral I'm a
little disturbed I want to know how the
hell tree trunks got lemongrabs essence
all up inside her so that she can
squeeze it all back inside him that was
that was scary this I like tree trunks
and that was creepy
no this is one of my favorites cuz if
she'll be like everything going on
Shelby was like what the is wrong
with you people
tree trunks does that means like Oh God
like I love Shelby's voice I have to say
Shelby's voice really
I don't know why
just makes it so much funnier and then
because Shelby I can't remember Shelby
start off like this but got
progressively more cynical yeah you know
and so just bluntly saying what he's
saying and that last line you're right
like if another person said it would
have been fine but just kinda
high-pitched voice talking it it makes
it even funnier because you wanna hear
something really cupids than something
like just incredibly me yeah well no cuz
the first time I remember him popping up
with a line I'm fairly remember if
that's the one in this or not violin
viola viola that's why one of those
children's name viola when um when he's
wanting to figure out what's been in
Rainicorn and Shelby pops up and says
they should hang out together yeah but
Shelby's always been kind of like the
whole like yeah this is what's going on
deal with it yeah and I think but it
Shelby might write that hasn't had like
too much screen time no I wasn't devil
full episode yes well this is the
closest we have now and it's like he's
funny interacting off of these other
characters I mean like like you said I
mean this is how it is you know and I
don't care how it sounds you know sort
of attitude and yeah I think you would
have to be around like pathetic people I
think it's how you would be funny like
if these around tree trunks if he's
around Finn and Jake I don't think like
it could still be funny if they won't be
as funny as if you team up with Ice King
or something like that you know just
something where he can directly you know
say yeah no no I'm sorry we give lumpy
Space Princess in tree trunks entire
episodes well I can only give one to
Shelby so ya know I I thought was really
funny I thought just playing uh said the
slapstick was great that team you'll
these characters surprisingly worked out
that you mean to myself okay this is
either gonna be great or I am going to
hated this episode and I really liked it
and a lava is just the character
interaction yeah between them and
it's a really good voice acting with
these characters are all specifically
annoying in their own unique way but
somehow don't legitimately annoy you
they're all actually really funny so
yeah I I really liked it yeah I love
this episode on a side note I wasn't am
I the only one I wasn't thinking of
Twilight Zone the first thought that
came to my mind was cute oh yeah thank
you
first thing what the movie oh yeah I
guess those so the play act okay well I
don't think I forgot I was really hoping
this was got segue into a Fionna cake
episode that if it doesn't it'd be great
because I heard there's at least one
more
and because the Fionna cake was really
really fun and I really want to see if
that's in there I can't wait till next
week or you can stay for one more lousy
episode it's all of like eleven minutes
waiting a week
well I stay for one more friggin episode
find out if we are in the same clothes